Hey, everybody, Matt here for a DNews Short.
There may come a day when you’ll have dragonflies
to thank for improving your health.
Turns out, dragonflies are helping scientists
develop smarter medical devices based on the
unique bacteria-killing abilities of their
wings.
Scientists have known for a while that dragonfly
wings are composed of nanopillars, which are
small, spike-like pillars on the surface of
the wings.
But a new study in ASC Applied Materials & Interfaces
found that these nanopillars play a role in
killing bacteria by physically ripping them
apart.
The pillars are of varying sizes and look
similar to what scientists have referred to
as a bed of nails.
However, instead of puncturing the bacterial
membrane, as researchers previously thought,
the new study found that the bacteria secrete
a substance that traps them in the pillars.
You can see in this image here how the bacteria
become stuck on the dragonfly wing.
When the bacteria try to move, the force of
their adhesion to the nanopillars tears them
apart, spilling out their contents and killing
the bacteria.
Ouch!
Dragonflies aren’t the only insects with
this winged superpower.
The nanostructures of cicada wings are built
similarly.
However, cicada nanopillars aren’t tall
enough to kill certain bacteria that have
thick membranes, like MRSA and strep, whereas
dragonfly nanopillars can.
Inspired by the dragonfly and cicada wings,
scientists have started developing medical
materials that mimic the structure of nanopillars
in hopes of creating versatile bacteria-killing
surfaces.
The science has already made its way onto
many medical tools and could be used on food-processing
and even in public facilities.
These bacteria-ripping materials could have
a tremendous impact on everything from the
operating room to Monday morning’s busy
commute.
However, research is still very much underway,
and it could be a while before you can clutch
the railing of a crowded bus and not worry
about catching the next bug.
But when that time does come, I guarantee,
it’ll be all the buzz.
But did you know there are actually bacteria-eating
viruses?
Check out this video to learn more.
So what surface would you most want to be
covered in antibacterial coating?
Tell us in the comments, subscribe, and keep
coming back for more DNews everyday.